why never
again is the rallying Cry of all of the
people who fight to prevent another
Holocaust the amount of millions of
people that died was absolutely
unnecessary and it was something that we
should never ever repeat again now you
guys have heard of Arnold the
Schwarzenegger I'll be back I don't have
to get into who he is most of you have
watched many of his films the job a
vista
baby
recently he was asked about what's
happening in razza what do you do about
the Israel Palestine question and Arnold
Schwarzenegger gave his response I think
that what the Biden Administration is
doing is the right way to go you know I
think that we have to acknowledge that
Israel was attacked viciously unprovoked
I'm 100% with the Israelis in this case
uh but asalam greetings peace go ahead
and subscribe right now hit that
notification ification Bell so you don't
miss exciting programs just like this
one now my question to Arnold the
Schwarzenegger is have you seen Arnold
look have you seen the thousands the
thousands of innocent human beings the
latest count and it keeps going up was
over 88,200 innocent civilians you got
over
3300 number just keeps going out it's
like every every day kids are dying you
got so far over 3,300 innocent children
over
1,800 innocent women and we as Muslims
we have the Quran and was called the
Sunnah and this is easy for us we don't
justify even in war at any time the
killing of non-combatants this is clear
killing one innocent beings in the Quran
is as you killed the whole of mankind
saving one Innocent Lies as if you saved
the whole of mankind and if you didn't
know the instructions that Prophet
Muhammad gave went in a battle he
prohibited killing innocent human beings
non-combatants so Arnold we're not
connected to any political party we are
doing this sincerely to help no matter
on what side it is innocent human lives
innocent children to help be a voice for
those who are voiceless so I'm asking
you that question have you seen this
Arnold beyond the mainstream media
narrative have you taken a deeper dive a
deeper look into this are you seeing the
footage that is coming out of all these
children with just being dismantled body
parts all over the place have you Arnold
Schwarzenegger also had an anti-hate
message that went viral why never
again is the rallying Cry of all of the
people who fight to prevent another
Holocaust I would just kind of confused
why he didn't why you didn't Arnold
address the hate that's coming out out
from the country that you endorse here
get the out of the country this is
Jewish country only we don't need
Muslims The Godly thing to do we respect
one another The Godly thing to do is
just to kill you The Godly thing is to
kill me that's right that's what the
Torah says the Torah says to kill us the
Torah says that Idol people who worship
Idol such as yourself when there is a
Sanhedrin to kill us yes okay that's
what the Tor say we know the Jewish
people feel about Christians yes that
you discriminate against Christians
Christians are Idol discriminate against
Tor says that Christianity is idol
worship before Israel 1948 it was
Palestine yeah oh no it's called isra no
it it was called Palestine before 1948
maybe it is and it still is right now
it's occupied Palestine yes yeah I wish
more children okay and I wish the ID
find you and you okay why okay
only isra no Palestine and if you talk
it like again I will you in your okay
mother wait does he kill innocent
Palestinians i k every palestin so every
Palestinian you see you
K because us we we don't say we stand by
a certain political party a certain
party resistance party you're not
hearing us say that so the people who
are saying look we stand with I'm 100%
with the Israelis this Theodore
Herzel Prophet who organized and made
this stay and then you're standing
behind this you're endorsing this now
you are the one who should be answering
the questions do you endorse the killing
of innocent human life it's kind of like
you know if you had a school shooter
came in and he came into a public school
with hundreds let's say thousands of
kids in there in Auditorium and next
thing you know would you endorse for the
whole building and everybody in it to be
just annihilated to be killed I mean to
be bombed I mean would you does that
make any sense but this is what's
happening and then excuses obviously are
being given this was not unprovoked this
was provoked by Decades of occupation of
killing of surveillance of prison camp
you know what what's your answer look I
mean I'm sure that always people will
have an excuse to justify it so in this
an anti-hate you included so many people
in this I've seen enough people throw
away their futures for hateful beliefs
it was more geared towards your visit
you know to this evil event that
happened and this was something that the
Jews at that time look don't take it
from me take it from a rabbi let's go to
this clip and you can actually see the
history here and you can go this is what
I'm talking about taking a deeper dive
have you because if I start talking
about how Jews have always fled
persecution from actually Christians s
to say and they've come to the Muslims
to the Muslims they have seeking Refuge
they flourish let's take a second to
look at this clip from an actual Jewish
rabbi till Zionism came about Jews
flourished as as distinctly religious
Jewish communities and they weren't
massacred on the contrary they went to
these Arab and Muslim lands to escape
persecution uh from the Crusades from
the Inquisition and from many other
trials and tribulations and the um and
even World War II uh the Arab and Muslim
lands opened their hearts opened their
lands and uh provided a safe haven and a
gracious Hospitality for the Jewish
people clearly they we we have different
religion and yet uh we were we were
accepted in these Muslim and arbl we
believe in one God and we were accepted
we have different ways of serving God
but yet as I we were respected and even
the Muslim religion requires of that of
of the uh the Muslim people to to
provide protection and hospitality and
they did uh carry that out that's clear
nobody could refute this fact so this is
historically documented and you can also
look at the history when Muslims were
ruling Jerusalem when they were in
charge you had peace between Muslims
Jews and Christians it wasn't all of
this Bloodshed and all this Injustice
that's happening now and the Islamic
uh Warrior saladan conquered the
Crusaders MH and took control of
Jerusalem all right he entered into an
agreement that that that the Muslims
would protect the Christian
churches and so he appointed two Muslim
families both of these families had been
in Jerusalem for uh you know close to A
Thousand
Years and each generation has passed
down the key the key this is a Muslim I
mean AD Judah is a Muslim and he said
it's also it's a great honor for Muslim
to hold the key to the Church of the
Holy sea which is the most important
Church in
Christendom that's not disrespect that's
we don't hear this in America we don't
hear guess what what we have been told
is Christians Christian Americans and
you know you you should hate Muslims you
should kill Muslims cuz they they're
going to tear down all the churches and
and and uh you know basically just rans
sack them and everything else but here
we have two families that for nearly a
thousand years have actually been
watching over yes Christian CH that's
right so who planted into our minds here
in America that we should hate and kill
Muslims who planted that thought in our
head so Arnold what about the anti-hate
towards the people there who are in an
open not I wouldn't even say it's a
prison because even prisoners have
certain rights we're talking about this
is one of the largest concentration
camps that they're in right now I TW
aitz the Nazi concentration camp so you
went to go see what was done in history
you're seeing it now repeat itself why
aren't you speaking up Arnold why AR
they be peacemakers why aren't they
calling for peace why aren't they
negotiating why aren't they putting
pressure on Israel you have to stop
treating the Palestinians like they're
animals you say you're the children of
God but you treat the Palestinians like
their rats why aren't these Christian
leaders telling the Jewish Zionist this
is ungodly you say you're the chosen
people of God you can't behave like this
now you did say that Palestinians have a
right to live the Palestinians have a
right to live it's very nice but let's
unpackage that Arnold I'm an Israeli
Jewish American as well my partner is
Palestinian and I can do things that he
can't do um I can travel quite freely
and even though his mother is a refugee
from what is now is Israel he can't pass
areas that are off limits to
Palestinians I have um excellent rights
I have health there are cities in Israel
being built for Jews only and also in
the West Bank settlements being built
for Israeli Jews only while Palestinians
are hemmed in unable to build cities and
their homes are being demolished for
lack of permits that are almost
impossible to get um the Israeli
authorities are engaging in forcible
transfer where they remove Palestinian
communities in the West Bank to make
room for settlements all of these are
part of the root causes of the violence
there's terrible abuses going on you
just have to listen to what people on
the ground are telling you and adjust
accordingly let's unpackage that that
right to live what is that what's
something that you'd approve of do you
Endor that they live under two sets of
different laws one for the followers of
Theodore Herzel is actually to maintain
an aparte system very uh very early on I
understood that the rights that the
Jewish settlers have are not the rights
that the Palestinians have I understood
that I cannot touch a Jewish settler if
he is attacking a Palestinian the best I
can do is call a local police department
to come handle it like I would do at
home in Jerusalem so these Jewish
settlers that live in Kon are living
under the same rights that I live in in
Jerusalem but the Palestinian next to
them next house over next building over
sometimes next apartment over lives
under my rule my military rule and I can
do whatever I want with him I can take
his home as a temporary base for a few
hours to a few days to a few weeks I can
decide that I'm arresting the people of
the house and tying them up to defense
of my
base um if you will get in order to
demolish their home or just lock their
front door and don't let them out into
the street their houses on a street that
only Jewish settlers can walk on and
Palestinian cannot so they have to walk
through Windows to yards into the other
side into the kaso of Kon I think
realizing all of that in a very very
early stage in my
service helped me understood that
someone was lying to me along the way I
didn't feel like I'm protecting anyone I
didn't feel like I'm helping anyone
feeling more safe I feel like I'm
terrorizing people two sets of laws for
two different people do you agree with
this do you endorse this Arnold don't
take it from me let's let's look at
people who are also part of the
terrorizing of these innocent people
what they have to say you have 650
combat soldiers on a day-to-day basis
and I was one of these 650 soldiers for
a while and that's their job to make
their presence felt you start your night
ship Patrol 10:00 till 6:00 in the
morning 8 hour
shift walk in the streets of the old
city break into a house it's not a house
we have intelligence about a random
house I'm the Sergeant I leave the
patrol choose a random House break into
the house wake up the family men one
side women the other side searched the
place you can yourself imagine the
Dynamics what happens when you break
into a family 2:00 at night wake
everyone up search the place finish go
out to the street knock on some doors
Make Some Noise run to the other corner
of the street invade another house wake
up the family search go out run to the
other corner of the old city another
random house and that's basically how
you pass your 8 hour
shift 24 hours a day 7 days a week from
September 2000 when the second in
started till today it didn't stop for
one
second yeah the idea is very simple
every Palestinian needs to feel the
military is right
here yeah you never know when we're
going to show up when we're going to
start when we're going to end how many
we're going to be what we're going to
do it's to do what we call in the
military to create the feeling of being
chased can you imagine that these were
people it's their job every Palestinian
needs to feel the military is right here
X on the back of back of these innocent
people can you imagine someone coming in
your house coming in your house
terrorizing your family this what the
guy's describing this was his job so you
are you okay with this Arnold I'm 100%
with the Israelis in this case two sets
of laws for two different people it's
called the partti you've met Nelson
Mandela you met him what Nelson Mandela
had to say about this about the
Palestinian people his work continues
also with his family members let's take
a look at what his grandson has to say
about this we can no
longer stand idle while we watch our
brothers and sisters being murdered by
the Zionist state of
Israel apartate has been declared a
crime against humanity and apart Israel
is an apartate State Arnold
Schwarzenegger also he mentioned that
it's something we should never repeat
again just say to people that the
arities that were committed the amount
of millions of people that died was
absolutely unnecessary and it was
something that we should never ever
repeat again again he's referring to the
Holocaust this was something evil Islam
condemns this most Muslims condemn this
but now things like the Holocaust of our
evil what about the Muslim also
Christians who are there who are going
to the same
thing will you speak up against this
Arnold more recently in 2012 during a 60
Minutes piece the late Bob Simon dared
to report on what day-to-day life is
like for Palestinian Christians who live
under Israeli occupation Israel has
occupied the West Bank for 45 years
turning the little town where Christ was
born into what its residents call an
open air prison Christi anastas lives
with her mother Claire her father
brother and sister in this house which
is surrounded on three sides by the wall
how do you live with this a Simon's
report was seen as so unusual and so in
Century that Israeli Ambassador Michael
Ain actually tried to it censor it
leading Simon to directly confront him
on camera when I heard that you were
going to do a story about Christians in
the holy
land and my assum and
and had I believe information about the
nature of it and it's been confirmed by
this interview today nothing has been
confirmed by the interview Mr Ambassador
because you don't know what's going to
be put on air okay I don't true Mr
Ambassador I've been doing this a long
long time and I've received lots of
reactions from just about everyone I've
done stories about but I've never gotten
a reaction before from a story that
hasn't been broadcast
yet well was the first time for
everything
Bob Arnold Schwarz also mentioned how
the German people were lied to and that
we can learn from those mistakes from
those mistakes of miscommunication how
the people in Germany were lied to and
how we can learn from these mistakes and
uh how now uh you know people are
running around and trying to spread
those kind of lies in America and all
over the world but you're seeing we're
seeing right in front of us unfolding
the lies the atrocity propaganda and the
the direction and the motivation of
hatred has never really paid off you
know I think there's a better way of
going and this is to come together and
not to villainize each other but to come
together and to figure out a way how we
can coexist and how it's being repeated
over and over and pushed by the
mainstream media and this is helping to
dehumanize the Muslim Christian
Palestinians over there so then they can
go ahead and fulfill the agenda so they
can go ahead and make it easier and get
the support from the American public and
the world to go ahead and continue with
this ethnic cleansing with the
extermination the Holocaust of these
innocent children do you approve of this
Arnold one go a that will overshadow the
Naka of 48 Naka in Gaza and Naka to
anyone who dares to join I mean you know
this well the propaganda machine the
atrocity propaganda at that time how the
Jews were called rats how they were
called and made they were called
disgusting names and what happened they
were dehumanized they were oppressed and
now it seems like the oppressor is
become the oppressed has become the
oppressor and you have so many Holocaust
Survivors and others who have tried to
come out and speak against this they've
been demonized and I found out that it
wasn't exactly like that that in order
to make this Jewish dream a reality we
had to visit a nightmare on the local
population and there's no way you could
have ever created uh a Jewish
State without uh oppressing and ex
expelling the local population Jewish
Israeli historians has shown without a
doubt that the explosion of the
Palestinians was persistent it was
pervasive it was cruel it was
murderous and with deliberate attempt
so that's what's called the Naka in
Arabic the disaster or the catastrophe
there's a law that you cannot deny the
Holocaust but in Israel You're not allow
to mention
Thea even though was at the very basis
of the foundation of the state you know
you have Israelis and Jews okay it feels
important to say this I am not pulling
my perspective on Israel Palestine out
of my ass okay I'm not just guessing
that Israel is committing a genocide
against Palestine I have studied and
researched this I have bonafides and I
will share them first of all I'm a
Jewish woman I was raised by a Zionist
family my grandfather was a holocaust
Survivor my family talked about our
spirit of resistance and resilience
constantly Desiring goodness from the
nation of Israel is in my blood and
still I can see that this Zionist state
is vicious violent and evil if someone
who is raised by a Zionist family by
people who believe that Israel has the
right to exist and that it is our
Salvation if I can overcome my
pro-israel bias and learn about this
conflict so can you and frankly I should
not be calling it a conflict it's a
genocide Israeli historians Israel's
perception of itself is of a very decent
liberal uh peaceloving
country uh which was surrounded by
predatory Arabs and it had no choice but
to stand up and defend itself so this is
a defensive war and uh there is great
reluctance to look at the dark side of
this war particularly at the ethnic
cleansing that happened in
1948 the broader historical context for
this film is the ethnic cleansing of
Palestine in
1948 uh over 500 Villages were Arab
Villages were destroyed
750,000 Palestinians were made refugees
Benny Morris counted 28 massacres of
which tantura is only one so it's not an
isolated episode Israeli human rights
organizations inside and outside of the
country who have condemned this who have
also spoken up have you taken a deeper
look into this and what they had to say
so these are not people who are
following the way of the prophets even
though they are using the Bible using
this to try to
justify this Holocaust to justify this
extermination of a people this is not
something that God almighty this is we
have in the Quran where God is telling
us woe to those who write the book with
their hands we know that the previous
scriptures were changed altered you know
when they quote when you have even
rabbis and you have others it's
unfortunate on this side that follow not
the prophet one of the mightiest
Messengers sent to mankind Moses peace
be upon him who's one of the most
mentioned mentioned prophets in the
Quran you think he would go ahead and
support this do you think now that they
would stand behind this only innocent
people that are in Gaza now are the
229 hostage that were taken once they
will go back to Israel we will P shifa
hospital all the hospitals all the
tunnels and kill them all it's about
time these are people who follow a
Prophet by the name of Theodore Herzel
not Prophet Moses these are those same
people who changed the text to justify
so when they quote verses like Samuel 1
there is no permission from the Torah to
have any Mercy
whatsoever during war not on children
not on women not on anybody and come in
when they come into the town and
annihilate men women children donkey
whatever is alive just destroy it and
you sing it right and people are not
making the connections you see people
that you see the man getting up there
and them and they're talking about
annihilating a whole people and using
the Bible to justify it where's the
outrage you must remember what Amal has
done to you says our Holy Bible and we
do remember and we are fighting our
brave troops and combatants who are now
in Gaza or around Gaza and in all other
regions in
Israel are joining this chain of Jewish
Heroes a chain that has started 3,000
years ago from Joshua no so these are
not the people following the example of
the prophets know because God Almighty
sent them with the same message to
worship the Creator not the creation to
be morally upright and what kind of
morals are these killing
indiscriminately innocent men women and
children this is something that is an
Abomination this is something that's
evil and this is something that even
though now they're trying to use it
there these are those texts that have
been altered and changed because the
scriptures that we have what we have of
of those they have been altered and
changed that's why God alight and this
is an example of it because there's no
way that the all loving the most
merciful Creator the heavens and earth
is going to give people like this a
green light and most of these people
don't even believe in God these are this
whole movement was started by people who
are atheists void of God this is a
nationalistic Supremacy movement because
people of God you have good Jewish
people you know good Christians you have
people of God who truly not now people
who are trying to endorse this justify
this seeing this evil take good people
who are seeing this evil taking place
and their hearts are alive they have
some kind of moral compass still it's
working they see that the all just is
not going to give a green light to this
in these injustices this is pure evil
man this is just evil so Arnold it's
your call take a deep dive you probably
get some now some love from the Muslims
who will help to facilitate maybe share
maybe you don't have a Muslim friend
meet them Muslim meet someone a
Palestinian someone who can go ahead and
educate you in this matter because a
person can live almost like you your
whole life and you've been just
following the mainstream narrative you
got to take a deeper dive there's so
many documentaries there's so many so
many people who've done some sincere
independent investigating reporting on
this it's like a detective you look at
one side you're like hold on okay
something here it goes to the other side
he gets hey he gets a he gets a c
picture goes again back to the other
side here's the same talking points then
he goes back and then he's like hold on
he he's starting to see how these things
are falling apart there's a context to
it it's not the this whole narrative
that's been given to him is not adding
up but you had to take that first
sincere step to go ahead to get the
whole picture because it's not something
that's confusing and vague they try to
make it like that it's something very
straightforward and clear if you want to
know the truth you're sincere you're
humble hearted and and more importantly
we made a video for you Arnold you can
just type in Arnold Schwarzenegger for
those who haven't seen that put Islam in
front of his name and we invited him to
the way of Moses to the way of Jesus to
the way of Abraham that complete and
total submission and surrender to the
creator of the heavens and earth
submission to the will of God in one
world that's defined as Islam and then
when you look into this you might like
Liam Nissim had once
said then I thought maybe Islam's the
answer and I want to leave you with this
a message from a Jew himself he says as
a Jew I've been to many Holocaust
museums they often have a pile of shoes
or clothing of those who were killed
it's painful to see it's moving one day
there will be a museum to remind us of
all the genocide that's been perpetuated
against the
Palestinians it very well might have a
pile of thousands of children's shoes
will you be able to say you did what you
could to stop the
massacre will you you have a great
responsibility Arnold Schwarzenegger and
your time is almost up you're at the end
of the road of life should do some good
in the world ask the creator of the
heavens and the Earth alone for guidance
and be a voice for justice a voice true
voice for peace thank you very much
peace be with you assalam alaykum cannot
leave without giving you a gift if
you're not yet Muslim and you're tuning
in to see what these Muslims are talking
about and you like a free copy of the
Quran go ahead and visit theen show.com
we'll take care of the post M and
everything and get it delivered to you
and if you still have some questions
about Islam call us at 1 1800
66247 52 we'll see you next time until
then peace be with you assalam alaykum
brothers and sisters we've all had loved
ones that passed away a mother a father
a brother sister a close family member
but one of the mercies of our Dean is
that with the right intention we can go
ahead and continue to do good deeds on
our loved ones behalf and what greater
of a continuous Good Deed Sakia
investing on their behalf in the dean
Center a mjid and mega dawa Center that
will benefit generations to come
inshallah so click the link below donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you